he is recognized as the greatest athlete
of modern times in the boxing ring he
was nothing short of superb punishing
his opponents at will you know his
outside of the ring that he would have
his greatest battles and show the world
what it really meant to be a man in this
episode of Pi graphics we discover what
it was that made Muhammad Ali the
absolute greatest it's just a job
grass grows birds fly waves pound the
sand I beat people up
[Music]
kasia's Marcellus clay was born on
January the 17th 1942 in a Louisville
Kentucky his father cassia C Mia was a
sign painter while his mother Adair Sur
worked as a maid for a wealthy white
family in Louisville a precocious but
polite child young Cassius was raised as
a god-fearing Baptist along with his
younger brother Rudy in his younger
years he gave no indication to his
athletic future he steered clear of
sports preferring to play marbles with
Rudy Bohr read comic books on his bet in
1954 when he was 12 years old
Cassius and a friend rode their bicycles
to the Columbia Auditorium which was
hosting the Louisville home show they
spent the afternoon
checking out the wares of various
African American merchants and gorging
themselves on the free popcorn and candy
that was on offer when they emerged from
the exhibition the boys were dismayed to
discover the Cassius's brand's new red
and white Schwinn bike was missing the
bike well it had been stolen
kasia's was absolutely livid with rage
crying and upset he began asking people
if they'd seen who took his bike a woman
suggested that he report the theft to
officer Joe Martin who operated a boxing
gym the nearby basement finding Martin
Casius explained of what has happened
adding that he was going to what whoever
had taken his bike Martin who had been
teaching boxing for decades asked if the
boy knew how to fight
when Casius admitted this he didn't the
officer suggested that maybe he better
learn and well this this was the
beginning of a long friendship and two
glorious career
[Music]
Casius he threw himself into boxing
training with a passion and commitment
that impressed Martin although he had
very little natural skill he had more
heart than anyone else in the gym it
raced to the gym as soon as school let
out and would train even on Saturdays
Martin had simply never seen a kid work
quite so hard outside of the gym Casius
stayed away from anything that would
interfere with his training he was
displaying the kind of determination and
discipline that was lacking in many of
the older boxers that Martin coached
Martin he introduced Casius to the local
boxing trainer named Fred stoner who
helped teach him the fundamentals of the
sport under the guidance of these two
men young clay began winning one I met
about after another month after month
year after year a handful of amateur
wins built up a formidable record by the
age of 18 he had won 108 bouts six
Kentucky Golden Glove championships and
two national AAU titles in the ring
kasia's absolutely fearless
he carried self confidence and a belief
in his ability that put his opponents
off guard before the first round Bell
that even sounds it but this was in
great contrast to his personal life
because there he really struggled there
was a poor student with teachers unable
to understand why he couldn't transfer
the dedication he put into his sport
into his studies no one realized at the
time that his struggles in school they
were due to the reading disability
dyslexia in February of 1957
professional boxer Willie Pastrano
visited Louisville with his trainer
Angelo Dundee kasia's found out where he
was staying and fern Pastrana's hotel
room phone was picked up by Doug Dean
Casius blurted out that he was going to
be the world's greatest boxer and that
he wanted to meet Pastrana with nothing
on their schedule that afternoon Dundee
and Pastrana actually invited Casius to
that hotel room for the next several
hours Casias peppered Pastrana with
questions only pausing long enough to
predict his own future greatness of
amused Angelo Dundee was impressed with
a boy and kept in touch with him he
sometimes sends Casius and his family
free tickets when one of his boxes had a
fight lined up in Lou
[Music]
in March 1959 Casius was training in a
gym in Chicago Illinois prior to an AAU
title bout ever heard some other boxers
talking about a group called the Nation
of Islam who were responsible Act pride
back home in Louisville he decided to
learn more about the group by doing a
school assignment about them however his
teacher shut the idea down telling him
that the group was dangerous and they
preached hatred against all white people
clay however was still intrigued by the
Nation of Islam he got a hold of a copy
of a newspaper the vapor at house and
started reading as much as he could
about them at the same time he was
wrestling with the weighty decision
about what direction to take his boxing
future people who have been talking him
up as a hot prospect for the 1960
Olympics in Rome but at that time only
amateurs were able to compete in the
Olympics so he had to decide if he was
going to turn professional or compete in
Rome as part of the United States's
boxing team it was at this point that he
turned to his friend Angelo Dundee for
advice Dante told Casius that he could
earn more money as a pro if he was an
Olympic champion first as a result he
decided to stay in his amateur career
and compete in the Olympics by the time
the American Olympic team was set to
depart for Italy clay was in peak
physical condition and mentally primed
for victory but there was one slight
problem he was absolutely terrified at
the prospect of flying on a plane in
fact he was so terrified that he almost
passed up the opportunity to represent
his country he only finally relented
when its old men saw Joe Martin
convinced him to fly and we think
parachute on his back fortunately
Casillas didn't need to operate his
parachute in the plane touched down in
Rome without any incidents he started as
Olympic campaign with a quick two round
win over the Belgium's Yvan because that
win was followed by another win over the
Soviet Union's
n radish at coffe he was the previous
gold medal winner at the 1956 Olympics
Casius then triumphed in the semi finals
defeating Australia's Antony Madigan the
only person standing between clay and
Olympic glory was Poland's
new pet osakowski in contrast to cassia
Seward only been boxing for six years
this man was a three-time European champ
and even at one bronze in the 1956
Olympics however it was clay who played
the more aggressive game throwing an
avalanche of punches to take the first
round lead the Polish champ well he was
simply unable to recover at the ends of
three rounds
kasia's claimed the olympic a light
heavyweight gold medal Casius he returns
in Louisville a local hero with even the
mayor turning out to receive him he was
so proud of his victory that he wore his
gold medal everywhere about a week after
his return he and a friends ducked into
a restaurant to get out of the rain but
when they tried to order a couple of
cheeseburgers and milkshakes they were
told that the restaurants did not serve
black people and they were thrown out
kasia's Clay was an Olympic champion yet
he was still a second-class citizen in
his hometown standing on the 2nd Street
bridge he grabbed his gold medal ripped
it from his neck and threw it into the
Ohio River
[Music]
despite his frustration with the social
climbers Casius was facing a bright
boxing future turning professional he
was sponsored by a group of local white
businessman who agreed to sponsor him
they offered to pay him ten thousand
dollars upfront and to cover all of his
training expenses in return they would
take half his earnings for the next six
years despite his impressive victories
in Rome boxing pundits didn't expect a
great career for clay the consensus was
that he had quick footwork but not much
else he spent too much energy they said
dancing around the ring and when he
leant back to protect his face he would
leave his body exposed
however Casillas relied on his long
reach to strike his opponents from a
distance Casius well he wanted to train
under Angelo Dundee but his sponsors
sent him to California to work with a
trainer by the name of Archie Moore he
made his pro debut in front of his home
crowd on October the 29th 1960 as
opponent was Tunney Hunsaker Clay won
the fights with a unanimous six round
decision it was a great start to his pro
career but clay wasn't happy with Archie
Moore's training style and he headed to
Miami and asked Angelo Dundee to take
over as his trainer Dundee agrees but
and then the Casius had to live in a
very rough neighborhood that was filled
with gangs drugs and prostitution still
he took immediately to his new training
environment flourishing under the
tutelage of Dundee by now it became
evident that Casius was an absolutely
masterful self-promoter
in fact his mouth it worked faster than
his fists he never tired of announcing
that he was the greatest the prettiest
and the fastest athlete to ever step
into a ring but it was soon encouraged
to talk himself up even more in June of
1961 clay traveled to Las Vegas for a
boxing match while in Vegas he went to
see a wrestler by the name of gorgeous
Jorge Casius watched as Jorge acted
outrageously he was trash-talking his
opponent for an upcoming match he talked
endlessly before bad and even during the
match the whole crowd well that made
them root for the other guy but after
the match Casillas met Jorge backstage
the wrestler explained that his
self-promotion was designed to get as
many people as possible to pay to come
and see someone at shut his mouth he
advised clay to keep
asking his opponents and to always be
outrageous he also told him to find
himself a gimmick that would set himself
apart well clay he soon found his
gimmick he would predict the round that
he would win the match him
on November the 15th 1962 Casius met his
former trainer aren't she more in the
ring more claims that he had developed a
lip button a punch to finally silenced
the Louisville lip as Casius had come to
be known in response clay predicted a
fourth round knockout and that is
precisely how the fight went down Casius
he was now a 16 win zero loss pro he
felt he had another shot at the
heavyweight world champion Sonny Liston
he engaged upon a campaign of taunting
lists and into taking the challenge he
began referring to the champ as a big
ugly bear and once even traveled to his
hometown of Springfield Colorado and
banged on his door at 3:00 in the
morning to call out the champ clay he
made absolutely sure that TV cameras
were recording every second of this
charade
finally Liston well-hit had enough and
he agreed to take on the upstart the
heavyweight champ made a prediction of
his own and that would be pain
there was no idle threat Liston was a
mountain of a man who had a killer punch
it was considered by many boxing experts
to be unbeatable Casius he trained hard
for this the biggest fight of his life
but he didn't give it his absolute focus
both Casius and his brother Rudy they
were becoming increasingly interested in
the Nation of Islam they started
attending meetings and Kassius became
enamored with the leader Elijah Muhammad
he also took a great liking to the
group's spokesman Malcolm X as the
brothers started spending more time at
the mosque in Miami Malcolm told Casius
to wear his Nation of Islam membership
proudly when the title fight sponsors
learned that the Challenger was
associating with the Nation of Islam
they threatened canceled the events and
eceive disavowed the group but claimed
he would not abandon his newfound faith
he was prepared to walk away from boxing
to stay true to himself well the
sponsors they ultimately backed down and
the fight it did go ahead now Liston he
was used to knocking out opponents in
the early rounds but claimed he was too
fast
his quick feet danced around the ring
and Liston was simply unable to touch
him after a grueling six rounds Liston
he refused to come out for the seventh
the 22 year old Casias clay was now the
youngest heavyweight champ in history as
great a shark as his win was it was
superseded the very next day when he
officially announced that he was a
of the Nation of Islam and that he was
changing his name to Kassius X a week
later that evolved into Muhammad Ali the
Nation of Islam they were very unpopular
with most of America it was predicted
this if he fought Liston again
there wouldn't be anyone rooting for him
well the two they did meet again on May
the 25th 1965 many in the anxious crowd
they expected to see Liston win back the
title that he had lost Ali instead they
were stunned to see the former champ
again knocked out in the first round on
November the 22nd 1965 Ali successfully
defended his title against former champ
Patterson Patterson had spoken out
against the Nation of Islam and refused
to call Ali by his Muslim name Ali made
him pay for this slight mercilessly
pounding him while yelling watch my name
in 1966 Ali defended his title five
times four of those defenses being held
outside of the United States
On February the 6th 1967 he fought an
Ernie Terrell in Houston Texas Terrell
had enraged Ali by just like Floyd
Patterson before him refusing to call
Ali by his name the result was woman he
believed to be the worst beating ever
dished out in a professional boxing
match the champ that tortured Durrell
for the full 15 rounds bringing him just
short of a knockout and then backing off
only to wallop him again with further
combinations Ali won a unanimous points
decision
Alli's next battle would pit him against
the might of the United States
government on April the 28th 1967 he
turned up at the Houston induction
Center for the US Armed Forces when the
time came to him to step forward
signifying his induction Ali didn't move
he explains that his religious beliefs
prevented him from joining the Army and
killing people with whom he had no
quarrel he further stated that he could
not in good conscience give support to a
war that he felt was morally wrong
within 24 hours he had been stripped of
his heavyweight title as well as his
license to barks in every state in the
country in an instant that title he had
worked so hard for was simply gone when
the US government took away his passport
he couldn't even box overseas the
government's well they had effectively
taken away his livelihood
however the champ was never going to lie
down he became an unlikely hero to the
millions of young anti-war activists
around the nation he spoke at the most
prestigious universities where he was
introduced as the first national figure
with the courage to stand up against the
war in Vietnam still the late 1960s were
lean years Farley on August 17th 1967 he
married a Linda Boyd the next year they
had a child Miriam but Ali's name had
brought him opportunities and he managed
to make ends meet he did everything from
opening a restaurant called champ
burgers to Astoria in the musical big
time buck white as the years passed
Muhammad continued training in the hope
that one day I would get the opportunity
to reclaim his title finally towards the
end of the 1970s some promoters in
Georgia which didn't have a boxing
commission organized about against Jerry
quarry though slower than he had been
Ali won in a convincing fashion and now
well other states they considered to let
him fight again if he could get another
win under his belt he might even get a
shot at a reigning champ Joe Frazer
- get up Fraser Malley has a first
defeat Oscar Bonavena the fight almost
went the full 15 rounds with Bonavena
taking a reading of punishment but he
also dished out a level of abuse that
Muhammad had never had to withstand
before Syl moly Wan in the last round
TKO the fight of the century
the first ever between two undefeated
heavyweight champs took place on March
the 8th 1971 Fraser and early traded
blow after blow five years before Ali
would have easily dodged some of phrases
punches but now he could only take the
hits and fight through the pain and the
abuse the fight they went the distance
it could have gone either way but in the
end it was a unanimous decision - Fraser
Muhammad Ali he had suffered his first
professional loss still he was
determined to get back on top he
followed up his loss by winning ten
fights in a row but in his eleventh he
was stopped by the formidable Ken Norton
who broke his jaw but Ali he came back
in a rematch knocking out Norton in the
sixth round and after this well that
came the rematch that he was really
after he fought Joe Frazier who had lost
his title to George Foreman for the
second time on January the 28th 1974
winning in a 12 rounds unanimous
decision but early well he still did not
have his title back to claim it he would
have to defeat the new champ
this was the 24 year old Foreman who had
so far 140 fights and his last 8 hadn't
gone past the second round on paper it
looked like the 32 year-old Ali did not
have a chance the fighter took place in
Caen such as a year on October the 30th
1974 over the early rounds it appeared
as if Ali was out of his depth with
Foreman apparently pounding him at will
what Ali was actually doing was allowing
Foreman to punch himself to exhaustion
in the eighth round Muhammad came to
life and delivered a devastating series
of blows that put Foreman on the canvas
the champ had reclaimed his heavyweight
title
a year later he faced Joe Frazier for
the third time and he believed that this
was the hardest fought heavyweight clash
of all time round after round the
stunned crowd watched in awe as the
battered boxes
somehow fought Beyond exhaustion in the
end Valley was declared the winner
in the fourteenth round he was so
exhausted that he couldn't even stand up
to celebrate
an aging are the defendant his title
seven more times before squaring up to
an unknown challenger by the name of the
Leon Spinks on February the 15th 1978
arlene underestimated the Challenger
training lightly and not taking the
fight seriously enough that night he
lost his title to a man who didn't
deserve to be in the ring with him at
his prime eight months later despite
obvious signs of developing Parkinson's
disease he avenged the loss to claim an
unprecedented third world heavyweight
championship nine months later he
retired from the ring but his time out
of the ring would last for less than a
year on October the 18th 1980 he
suffered a crushing defeat at the hands
of his former sparring partner Larry
Holmes a year later he was dispatched by
a far less impressive Trevor Berbick
time well it had finally caught up with
Muhammad Ali over the next decade his
Parkinson's disease steadily got worse
the body that had served him so well was
giving up on him still he wasn't done
yet
in the late 1980s Muhammad Ali embarked
on a new career as a humanitarian
statesman and promoter of tolerance and
peace worldwide by the time he left us
On June the 3rd 2016 he was recognized
as one of the great men and certainly
the greatest athlete of the 20th century
so I really hope you enjoyed that video
if you did please do give it a thumbs up
below and do not forget to subscribe if
you haven't already for brand new videos
just like this every Monday and every
Thursday also check out some of our
other videos from the past over there on
the right you'll probably enjoy these if
you enjoyed those they're all
biographies they're all of notable
people like Muhammad Ali we've got loads
of others check those ones out on the
right and maybe watch some others if you
got some time and as always thank you
for watching